took about 35 years
of me doing experiments doing
trial and error studies basically to
find out what were the variables that
affected what and why did they do that
and if i just had two or three variables
then it would have been a year or two
but when you have
the number of variables goes up the
number of complication
you know the number of possibilities
goes up dramatically
so it took a long time to just be some
examples of these variables
like you said mental state well mental
state would be one
there's lots of various mental states
you can get into
some are more effective than others but
it would be
let's say we're doing something like
remote viewing okay if we're going to
remote view and we're going to review
targets
then there one is the is the mental
space that you're in
the attitude the feeling you know these
are all
qualitative um
subjective things so you have a mental
state of
where you're going or your mental state
my mental state where i am what's my
mental state and how do i get there
and it finds out that mental state and
attitude and beliefs
fears all that stuff are are part of the
part of the equation um
it then you have to look at the various
variables how do you
approach it what tools do you use do you
have the idea that you are
like you say there's a camera someplace
is that your metaphor
for what's going on because we just have
to make up metaphors for things because
we don't really understand how they work
so you make up a metaphor okay there's a
camera over there
and i'm going to see what the camera
sees and now i can scan the camera you
know i get to
i get to move it around like it's on a
ball joint you know so you
we have these metaphors and you can work
through metaphors until the metaphor
doesn't break
breaks doesn't work anymore well
it's not really a camera because these
things you know
the camera wouldn't wouldn't see but i
see those things
so it's just a matter of testing
trying to if you do it enough you start
seeing
patterns you start seeing things that
work and things that don't
you start seeing similarities between
approaches
between healing and remote viewing and
other things
so i just we stuck with the paranormal
things because those are the evidential
things
and without evidence well you're just
out there
stuff happens and you could be making
all that up you know you could be
dreaming it you need the
you need the evidence to to verify it
so those are the kinds of things just
working with it looking for patterns
looking for structure looking for things
that
seem to always work